another creepy movie again house at the
end of the street otherwise known as
hates the hashtag for it weird right it
shouldn't even been called house at the
end of the street I don't even think
it's honest street it should be called
house at the end of BFE it's really what
it feels like you feel like you're in
the middle of the woods they talk about
their neighbors they even have
neighborhood gatherings but no there's
like two houses in the entire movie so
the story in house at the end of BF E is
that Jennifer Lawrence and her mom
Elizabeth Shue move into this house but
what happened in the neighbor's house
which is within spitting distance of
them is that their daughter slaughtered
and killed the parents and now the son
lives there and this is nice kid he's a
social outcast and everyone wants to
kick his ass you know because everyone
thinks they're a part of the Cobra Kai
group or something but Jennifer Lawrence
befriends him Minogue's he's a nice kid
and little do you know he's keeping his
little sister in a cellar all chained up
and no one can know about it and now we
have our movie our movie in which you're
intrigued by it a bit but if you really
deconstruct the movie to its core all
that's happening is a girl has a crush
on a dude and a dude has a crush on a
girl and that's what happens that's
that's the movie you watch teen romance
blossom it depresses me to say it
because in the end of this movie you
want to like it more than you end up
liking it those movies you walk out of
you're like yeah I like the twisting
right there is a twist in the movie and
it's actually a cool twist this twist
you don't really see coming or at least
I didn't see coming you really think
about the movie more and it doesn't
matter because you've seen everything in
this movie before it it's a bummer the
movies supposed to be this thriller
doesn't change the fact that it's a
Frankenstein version of a thriller
everything in this movie is from another
movie I mean Jennifer Lawrence is a good
actress but I want to see her stop
playing teenagers like she's gonna play
a teenager forever because she made a
lot of money playing a teenager because
she was Katniss and nothing will lock
down the teenage role more than being
Katniss that being said she's an
oscar-nominated actress what's she doing
in a house at the end of BFA you want
the movie to be a thriller and it is
kind of a thriller but it is just it's a
teen movies a teen romance movie with a
socially awkward kid who's a social
outcast and I mean that's combined a
socially awkward outcast kid developed a
romance with the chick who's out of his
league I'm not saying it's commonplace
and has happened for zillion times
before but it's pretty commonplace and
this happened four zillion times before
or I guess I'm bummed out because when I
was watching this movie I was like okay
he's got the crazy sister in the
basement you know this could be like a
modern-day Halloween type movie now and
I kind of respected that in that sense
it's a dated premise it really is but if
they were going for a modern take of
that that he could have been cool but it
really it's not that's not what it is
what it is is a socially awkward outcast
kid developed a romance with the chick
who's out of his league and that's what
the movie is so this movie had potential
I had hope for the movie when I walked
out of the movie I enjoyed the twist in
the movie I still got to give it props
for the twist because it was all cool
but this one thing in the movie doesn't
make up for the fact that I was bored
for an hour and a half there's no scene
in the movie where you're like oh that
scene is cool every scene in this movie
you're like I've been here before
I've been here before I've heard that
before in the end I will say you're not
gonna remember it t-minus one day yep
already forgot it Jennifer Lawrence just
don't pick movies like this is your
favorite suspense thriller movie I've
asked about horror movie but not
suspense thriller movie I don't think I
might have I've done a lot of videos but
I don't remember so hey whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you